let's now speak to Carol bachelor about
this she's the UN refugee agency special
advisor on statelessness and joins us
now live from Geneva thank you so much
for being with us
on al-jazeera we saw a success story
there in Kyrgyzstan but statelessness is
a problem that seems to be affecting
millions of people around the world just
how widespread is it and why is it so
persistent today
well every country in the world has to
decide which people are in the body of
citizens which people are members if you
like of the country and so each country
faces the risk that they might overlook
someone that someone might be
marginalized and we unfortunately
continue to see this not least because
stateless people themselves often live
in the shadows they don't have a legal
identity they are very fearful
frequently to come forward and say that
they exist they don't know who to
approach so we continue to see the
problem of statelessness both in the
extreme as you mentioned the issues of
state succession overnight the state
moves and everybody on its territory
might be at risk of statelessness as
well as all the way to individual cases
where a child's birth might not be
registered and as a just an oversight
they don't get a legal identity and this
is what UNHCR is seeking to change to
draw an end to statelessness by 2024 we
launched the I belong campaign for this
purpose so we're a stateless people
concentrated mostly today and what is
being done to help them most stateless
people that we know of and I have to
stress that because it's 78 states in
the world that report statistics on
stateless people on their territory
that's not even half of the states
globally so we know in those 78 states
there are almost 4 million
stateless people but we don't know the
details for all states globally so this
is one of our objectives
in the campaign that we have better data
we have statistics from states on who is
on their territory and if they're
stateless what's being done to help them
and UNHCR's particular responsibility is
to advise states to advocate to provide
technical and legal advice to go out and
find stateless people if that's
necessary to encourage States as people
to come forward once we can identify the
problem and the scope of the problem
then we can start to be truly effective
in solutions and that's what this came
campaign is about I'm pleased to say
that some states have removed gender
discrimination from their nationality
laws so that women can convey their
nationality to their children that helps
to avoid statelessness we've had 24 new
accessions to the statelessness
international legal framework this is
just in the first five years of the
campaign today here in Geneva we have
states organizations civil society
formerly stateless people we already
have over 200 pledges right to end
statelessness by 2024 so the main
outcome is do Ivana precisely what what
is the best approach to ending
statelessness is it a transnational
approach how how are you going about to
achieving this objective
I think that's an insightful question
because if we yeah every country does it
in isolation always someone will fall
through the cracks
we live in a world where people move
from state to state
people marry people from another state
children are born every day families
expand and so it's very important that
states collaborate it's not enough to
say well the person might be on my
territory but they weren't born here
they're not descended from my Nationals
they don't have their main links here so
I will not give my nationality there's
another step needed there and that's to
find out well who will we need to work
together and
we've been extremely pleased and
encouraged to see particularly at the
regional level a number of efforts to
bring States together so that they can
discuss who is doing what be sure that
their approaches are complimentary and
that no one's falling through the cracks
and this is what UNHCR is seeking to do
at the international level thank you so
much for taking the time to speak to us
Carol bachelor the UNHCR special advisor
on statelessness joining us on the
NewsHour from Geneva thank you for your
time